e
[Música]
a la vida y la imagen de la plenitud
está para mí es una de las imágenes que
nos pueden mostrar la plenitud de la
vida la juventud el contacto con la
naturaleza
ok hoy es un buen día para morir este
grito de guerra que los sioux entonaban
para defender sus territorios cuando
éstos estaban siendo más amenazados
este era una enseñanza de vida que los
sioux daban a sus hijos durante todo su
crecimiento que aprendieran que hoy es
un día el mejor día para morir porque
porque hoy vas a dar todo de ti con esta
frase quiero comenzar esta historia
esta historia habla sobre un chico de 18
años
que recibía muchas noticias de
apocalípticos futuros esos apocalípticos
futuros le decían que la mitad de los
bosques para el año 2000 y van a haber
desaparecido que prácticamente el 60% de
los mamíferos iban a ser extinguidos
para este cabalístico año
que la mayoría de los madres iban a
estar a significados y que la pesca iba
a ser sumamente difícil y que iba a ser
casi imposible conseguir un trabajo para
aquellas épocas
este joven apesadumbrado y un poco
atribulado por estas noticias tan
apocalípticas
decidió que iba a hacer algo
y lo que decidió
fue charlar con la madre tierra' hablar
con ella tratar de comunicarse con ella
y le dijo madre tierra
desde el día de hoy pongo mi vida en tus
manos yo ya no quiero decidir
llévame por los caminos que tú creas
donde soy más sutil así que tomó su
guitarra
como las cosas que cabían en su maleta
y salió a la primera esquina que
encontró a pedir aventón hacia el lugar
que fuera
después de un par de días logró llegar a
la ribera de un hermoso lago en un
pueblo precioso en ese lugar se encontró
ya con la noche encima y no supo dónde
dormir
se le ocurrió preguntarle a los policías
del lugar donde podría tener alojamiento
esa noche y ellos de manera burlona le
ofrecieron una celda de la comandancia
de policía y él pensó va es buen lugar
se quedó ahí a dormir a la mañana
siguiente en el centro del pueblo había
un gran mercado en ese mercado este
joven salió a cantar con su guitarra
para obtener algo para comer
después de haber cantado un par de
canciones se le acercó un sujeto de esas
personas que luego pueden denominarse
como hippies no cabello largo una ropa
muy usada
con una manera de comportarse como muy
ligera
y le preguntó oye chico tienes donde
quedarte
y el chico le respondió pues esta noche
no sé dónde me voy a quedar
y aquella persona le dijo sabes que creo
que encontré un lugar para ti
ese día por la tarde este chico arribó a
uno de los lugares más espectaculares
que había conocido en su vida en ese
lugar se llevaba a cabo un experimento
por personas de más de 15 países había
gente de sudamérica de norteamérica de
asia de europa que estaban
experimentando en una hectárea la manera
de vivir
autónomos de vivir autónomos y no sólo
eso sino además sin hacer daño a la
tierra y tratando de regenerar la en
este lugar existían tecnologías que
purificaban el agua de manera natural
también existían otras tecnologías para
captar los rayos de la luz del sol y
transformarnos una energía estas
personas dedicaban sus días a cultivar
su comida a preparar sus propios
alimentos a producir su propia energía y
a tratar de vivir en armonía con todos
los demás que vivían allí durante dos
años
este chico vivió en ese lugar
y descubrió que lo que él pensaba que
era un futuro apocalíptico
era una gran esperanza para el mundo que
había una manera de cambiar las cosas
experimento en su propia vida
como personas de distintas
idiosincrasias de distintas
nacionalidades podrían convivir en
armonía en tan solo una hectárea y
producir todo lo que necesitaban para
vivir
ese chico el día de hoy tiene 42 años y
tiene tres hijos y está frente a ustedes
dando una charla te
soy educadora ambiental
qué es un educador ambiental los
educadores ambientales nos dedicamos a
tratar de proporcionar las herramientas
adecuadas a las personas para que
aprendan a gestionar las problemáticas
ambientales a las cuales se ven
enfrentados estas problemáticas no van
solo con las cuestiones naturales sino
también tiene que ver con las cuestiones
sociales y las cuestiones económicas a
las cuales la sociedad se está
enfrentando en esta época
hay mucha información son muchos datos
los que yo les podría dar acerca de la
manera en la que los recursos del
planeta están siendo explotados la
basura que producimos la manera
inconsciente en la que contaminamos el
agua la manera compulsiva en la que
compramos y compramos y compramos cosas
y que esto está privando
de las mismas libertades a la siguiente
generación nuestra manera irresponsable
de gestionar estos recursos les está
quitando esa oportunidad a las
siguientes generaciones durante muchos
años los educadores ambientales
utilizamos esta estrategia decirles a
las personas oye qué cochino eres no
tienes basura oye éste recicla no
desperdicies tanta agua todo lo que te
compra se está yendo a la basura todo lo
que haces y esto provocó un efecto
contrario en las personas que justamente
lo que hacía era muchas veces sacar a
este
a esa persona indiferente que llevamos
todos dentro de nosotros y decir a cabo
no es mi culpa que lo resuelva el que
sigue es como si te dijeran voy a
enseñarte andar en bicicleta sí pero no
seas tonto pero no te vayas a caer pero
hiciste esto de esa manera tú no vas a
aprender
james lovelock
en su libro la teoría de gaia
nos expone de qué manera los seres
humanos somos parte de esta naturaleza
de la cual nos apartamos en algún
momento
somos parte del ecosistema y como parte
de él tenemos
la responsabilidad de convivir en
armonía con todos estos seres
la permacultura definida por beer
mollison nos da tres principios
cuidar de la gente cuidar de la tierra y
compartir equitativamente para de esta
manera poder gestionar esos problemas
una de las problemáticas a las que nos
enfrentamos los educadores ambientales
es a que las personas no conectan su
realidad con las realidades ambientales
que están viviendo porque no ven a dónde
va su basura no ven a dónde van los
desechos que están en el doble uso no
ven hacia dónde van todos sus
contaminantes porque nos hemos encargado
de esconderlos muy bien encontrar cómo
vincular a las personas con su ambiente
ha sido una tarea a la cual me he
dedicado por muchos años
y he descubierto en esta experiencia que
tuve en esta de cual de a que el vivir
la experiencia te da muchísimas
herramientas y te permite visualizar
muchísimos aprendizajes
encontré que el contacto con la tierra
el contacto con la naturaleza te decía
más que empezar te a culpar de cuánto
has contaminado de cuánto has destruido
y de qué tan pésimo es el mundo que le
vas a dejar a las siguientes
generaciones el tener contacto con la
tierra te ayuda a definir esto el ver a
un niño cultivar una semilla cultivar la
tierra te permite ver las consecuencias
de tus actos
las personas de una manera natural
disfrutan de la tierra
y llegó a este último punto el aula del
futuro como imaginamos que serán las
escuelas del futuro como imaginamos que
serán esos salones llenos de tecnología
llenos de computadoras donde tal vez con
la mano vamos a poder deslizar
información o si tenemos unos lentes que
nos mostrarán el mundo tal vez eso sea
nuestra próxima realidad
para mí estas son las aulas del futuro
estos pueden ser grandes laboratorios
donde las personas pueden aprender casi
cualquier ciencia
si hablamos de sociología si hablamos de
historia
si hablamos de física si hablamos de
química este es un gran natural de
laboratorio natural
los educadores ambientales tenemos dos
enfoques para trabajar uno de ellos es
el enfoque de trabajar acerca de la
naturaleza y esas son las clases que
tenemos en a lo mejor en alguna aula
donde damos datos o damos alguna
información y la que más me gusta a mí
es el enfoque de educación ambiental en
la naturaleza de esta manera nosotros
podemos encontrar un vínculo con
nuestros estudiantes donde
ofrecerles la oportunidad de tener esa
experiencia
ahora ya no le voy a decir eres culpable
de tanta contaminación eres culpable de
tantas cosas y no tiene y tu futuro va a
ser incierto lo que yo le voy a decir es
ahora cuida la tierra
escucha lo que te enseña
abre los ojos y mira que en tus manos
está la vida
estos chicos pueden comprobarlo
desde su tacto desde su oído desde su
vista de manera cotidiana
esta acción si ellos pueden cuidar un
pequeño jardín en su escuela serán más
conscientes de cómo cuidar este gran
jardín que es nuestro planeta mi
sugerencia para todos aquellos que
tienen a su cargo estudiantes para todos
aquellos que tienen en sus manos la
educación de las personas
denles la oportunidad de acariciar la
tierra tienes la oportunidad de vivir
con la naturaleza
huertas educativas para todas las
personas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]